top eight Anish giri he is also fighting
to qualify and his game against Juan Jun
has started what are we watching here
yeah it's early days but it's what we
call a fee and keto variation where both
sides have now uh put their Bishops on
Long diagnosed White's Bishop on the G2
Square black Bishop on G7 and it could
still transpose I was gonna say into a
grunfeld king's Indian it's more of a
king's Indian type of opening where
black will try and push a pawn in the
center most likely now there we go from
Anish giri but white setup is very solid
white puts up this Pawn Center and any
exchange of Pawns in the center means
that white has a bit more space but
black is relatively uh flexible black
can play on both sides of the board okay
I haven't seen Gary play like this too
often though so I'm pretty sure will be
happy all right well we're also joined
by
two rounds
round preliminaries try first of all
Anish giri coming for coming from a draw
is he feeling safe to qualify now for
the knockouts
he's in very good shape he's at 92 to
qualify
um but it's not quite set in stone yet
and how about you and Jun coming from
that important win against Hans Neiman
can you still become the first female
player to qualify
it is still possible uh for those who
really want to see chaos it's worth
keeping in mind that any of our intari
Hans Neiman Jew and June or even Sam
shankland still have a mathematical
chance if everything goes perfectly for
them in these last two rounds okay
exciting and obviously Levon aronian he
is currently in Ninth Place what will it
take for Levon to make it into topate
well he's gonna probably need to win a
game I'm not confident that two draws
will do the trick
uh they might
there's a lot of possible possibilities
it could take up to 22 or as little as
like 19 to qualify and he's already
on 18 but to really be safe I think he
needs to win a game if he wants to get
out of that sort of three-way race for
two spots that he's in with Wei Yi and
my Med you're off now wow and obviously
I I would say that maybe Anish giri mama
yarov and lavonaronian would have been
mentioned as the three of the top
favorites uh before the tournament
started is it likely that one of them at
least will miss the knockouts
there's a pretty good chance of one of
them missing since none of them are safe
and there's only four spots up for grabs
uh if way Yi qualifies then one of them
probably misses wow
it's going to be too uh intense final
rounds Ty thank you for joining we'll
talk to you again after this round
sounds great
Perfect all right well quite a few moves
in this one the bar slightly over to do
when you inside what kind of game is
this yeah this is heating up to be very
complex for intense game I've played
these positions a lot from the white
side and it's so hard to keep control uh
anishikiri's last move pushing Harry the
H Pawn that's got a bit of chaos
intended behind it black would love to
push that pawn even further maybe just
soften up the pawn structure around
White's King I was talking to a good
friend of ours Malcolm Payne an English
International master and he always said
in Rapid Blitz chess never play this
with white oh you always somehow get
softened up on the king side you always
get checkmated in the end and from my
experience that is quite uh is quite
likely every time I play Luke McShane
another English girl Master he always
seems to play this position suffer for a
long time as black and then eventually
Checkmate Me by using a few tricks so
um I think for classical chess it's
quite okay with white but uh yeah Blitz
and Rapid tricky sorry David I was just
saying you can see did you engines
laughing there again I just want to say
like we spotted yesterday and uh yeah
sorry to drive was just like it's quite
strange you know it's nice yeah I mean I
like saying that you know so uh what's
the women's world champion and we see
that the open world champion Magnus
Carlsen often do the same maybe it is a
world champion thing this is what you
need to do more just laugh yeah yeah
he's just thinking oh haha I'm better
than every other woman in the world yeah
maybe that's it that's a lovely Opera
way David I'm sure that's what Magnus
thinks as well
I am the boss can you get some uh
endorphins I want to say when you laugh
and when you feel happy and some kind of
chemicals are released yeah help your
concentration I think you also look like
a bit of a lunatic if you just go around
laughing the whole time and if you you
know just might not make any friends if
you're just laughing at your opponents
every game yeah yeah
know there's difference in laughter
right there's laughing at your opponent
when you're pointing your finger and you
go hahaha but then there's like
you know just like I'm having a good
time wherever I am in my mind and
everyone looks at you and goes you'll be
strange but look I'm down with it too
and they also walk away with a smile
I think if if my opponent started
laughing it'd be really off-putting
really yeah I'd be a bit weird you know
just I'll get really paranoid like what
are you laughing at you know if I played
a move why you laughed at one of my
moves so I don't know I wouldn't like it
yeah I don't know yeah be strange I
really don't like it when my opponents
smile at me but I learned the way to
stop them smiling is to just smile back
ah they smile at you just sit there
and then eventually they stop and they
get they get triggered uh make sure that
they're the ones who lose their cheers
really is my favorite sport
is a nice psychological War Games I've
never even heard of as an international
Master you know if I was found Dave and
I smile to him he smiled back I'm like
we're friends
with friends the surface it was a little
bit of a game being played yeah and
talking about making people smile what I
do have to share with you a selfie that
well
a photo that anas erda cherry has shared
with us because he says our help
commentary helps to kill time during the
evening evening ride back home in Dubai
oh and uh yeah
it's a it's Dubai have you ever been to
Dubai it's like full of Bright Lights
it's such a beautiful city and yeah you
know when you see this kind of cascade
of blue white yellow lights it's just
something fantastic and uh glad to be of
assistance and if you two want to send
or share with us a selfie share with us
your location or just send us your
thoughts then please tweet us using the
hashtag chess Champs and we will feature
them on the show
yeah and meanwhile a move from June she
wants to start expanding white already
has quite a lot of space with pawns but
she wants to especially kick away that
Black Knight on the queen side from a
very strong Square she wants to push her
B Pawn maybe we can jump in and discuss
some ideas because it's really risky
opening Choice from Anish giri I've got
to say uh White's last move pushing this
Pawn is intended to push the B Pawn next
and before white gets a chance to play
B4 uh what do you think black should be
doing
because if this happens for example if
black just makes a random move this
could be very annoying for black this
Knight is the pride and joy it needs to
retreat now
I don't really see how to stop this move
either
maybe hmm what else can we try Anish
giri his idea on the previous turn was
to push this Pawn forward just to
destabilize white over here
okay he actually just Retreats his
Knight I was gonna say this is on the
radar asking where to push forward but
now maybe some dark square holes in
White's position instead he Retreats the
Knight
what is the concept after white pushes
forward
does he just want to trade off a set of
Pawns maybe open up the A-line for the
black Rook because he just wanted to
step back with the Knight put some
pressure now on this guy
I'm gonna find out
that's mysterious isn't it because
white would like to initiate a set of
trades in order to help make her
position easier to play and I'm thinking
primarily dark Square Bishops okay yeah
I mean any other exchange I'm not 100
sure for white because white has space
black is cramped so actually black is
the one maybe trying to exchange pieces
to free up position but as you say your
van curve maybe if the dark squared
bishops come off for example
um let's try and make that happen yeah
something along these lines then yeah
definitely the dark squares now uh black
will feel weak or on these squares this
Pawn is especially weak now backward
Pawn easy target as well for white
spaces
yeah at the end of the world but uh
maybe some small issues here for black
yeah I mean I love playing these
positions as white generally uh they're
kind of Roxy bind I love having a bit
more space but I think you have to be
very careful as white when you start
pushing your pawns and a lot of time
Black's best strategy is just a weight
right and those pawns that Gwen Jun has
pushed they you know they're not
protecting each other anymore so maybe
this is uh what Anisha is thinking he's
thinking okay they're they're going to
be targets uh later on and you also have
to just be extremely patient
um in these types of structures but
um I don't know I mean I I think I think
Anish is doing okay for the night just
drops back now surely can't see anything
I mean it could drop back to this Square
as well maybe to come and attack you
mentioned the weak pawns this one is
undefended maybe this would be a one
idea the one thing I don't think he
should be doing is putting his Knight on
the edge of the board and that just
looks like a bad Square so yeah one of
these two squares looks very sensible
for the night
and it is a waiting game eventually I'm
slightly worried about why it's Pawn
structure I mentioned losing a few games
uh in my history I remember also
something very very similar to this when
I played some Blitz and rapper games
against Garrick sparov he managed to
beat me in these types of positions by
drop yeah but just yeah name dropping
but uh he really with some really
instructive Maneuvers managed to take
advantage of these pawns being loose and
something very similar to this he often
brought his Knight out tried to provoke
me to touch this Pawn
um often he would also push this Pawn
forward force me for example
uh say here to weaken and then he would
fix something on this Square
it's not easy to achieve right now for
black but yeah there's all sorts of
ideas later and maybe yeah I was gonna
say maybe Anish because he's played such
an ambitious opening he was uh always
going to keep pieces on the board so he
Retreats his Knight to the square no
exchanges he wants to LEAP into the
center maybe with this Knight maybe with
this Knight later
really tense I think objectively White's
probably better white has the advantage
in a classical game but in Rapid chess
there's a lot of space and therefore a
lot of squares to keep guard of for
white
yeah
it's uh yeah just one of those positions
I think I'm scarred by my personal
memories on this position but
objectively nothing to worry about yet
for sure yeah like you say you know I
also found the problem with this type of
position even in a classical game is
that you have to be precise right now
otherwise if you lose control then black
will get a lot of this counter play
that's just too hot to handle and the
problem with this time control is that
you know you're burning all the time so
when the critical moments hit say around
move 30 you're playing with one minute
on the clock yeah and things go wrong
and it is pushing those pawns to to you
too soon I mean it's kind of the typical
thing in a proxy bind when you have the
white Pawns probably highlight them just
on the light squares don't have to move
any pieces but this is kind of Roxy bind
setup and it you get this against a lot
of different black setups when you start
pushing your queen side pawns well they
can actually just it's really bad to do
that because pawns can't go backwards
and maybe David's here black can just
start attacking them I mean like why not
why not move the knight in you want the
B Pawn the white Pawn next to that to be
back now defending that one but it's not
it's gone too it's prematurely gone
forward so I think and Black's got a
very easy plant here the bishop can come
out and and attack that pawn again and
um it it actually starts to look a bit
uncomfortable I think for white
um because maybe maybe those pawns went
forwards a bit bit too quickly though
I mean the evaluation bar really hates
you and June's last move I said there's
nothing to worry about immediately but
maybe now as Simon points out how do we
defend this Pawn do you have to defend
it with the queen
it does feel a bit loose I don't see an
immediate knockout blow though so
maybe it's just to do with uh again
something that I've experienced just to
do with this Pawn pushing forward
undermining White's Duo over here if we
step forward again then black can start
taking control over the dark squares
maybe with the bishop maybe even with
the queen Coming forward kind of
sneaking into White's half
and uh if Black's Queen lands on this
Square
um for example the Knight might follow
in and
you can definitely imagine attack
Brewing against the white king
anisha's only been well only been able
to win three games so far in the
tournament is he struggling though to
sort of uh finish it off when he does
have a good position on the board
uh possibly he's I mean maybe that's
been his trademark in his earlier years
building up these great positions and
then not finishing them off there have
been a couple of games in this
tournament that I've seen at least where
he's played very very well but his
opponents have just played equally well
and it's uh
yeah sometimes that just happens
interests at the top level
and we have to remember he's I think
he's in the ape spot place just looking
at the scores now so it's really like
this is a key game only the top eight
players qualify and there's only two
games to go uh so just you know just
having a little update it looks like at
the moment a niche is an eighth and June
is in temp so this is this is really a
key game for qualification major game if
she wins this they will be on the same
score Wei uh was supposed to play rajabo
in this round so that's three points for
Wei who is now on 19 points so
definitely this is a game where a niche
needs points and it's a crucial game for
Jew and Jun
yeah I mean she's in a must-win
situation in this game and her next game
yeah on the plus side I did notice she
had White when she beat Hans Neiman in
the last round she's got white again and
I saw some stats a while ago um in these
round robin tournaments all play all
tournaments often players in uh half the
place they'll get double whites at some
point and normally if you win the first
game and you get white again in the
second game you tend to win again it's
just a pattern maybe it's just that
confidence boost of winning the first
White game I think there's some
statistics out there so just
maybe from that mindset point of view
she's thinking okay I'm in great form
with white just beat Hans Neiman and
white again now against Gary
he's not in the best of form
so she might try and take some risks
later to try and win but at the moment
there is a big threat facing her Black's
Knight has jumped forward so the White H
Pawn is under Fire twice from Black's
night and from blacks to light Square
Bishop
yeah how to defend push that pawn
forward
defend it with the King
I guess pushing pushing it forwards
makes sense to to force the Black Knight
to make a decision about what it's going
to do and I imagine a black knight will
come towards the center or something
David or unless Anish Gary is feeling
extra greedy so this Pawn is attacked
twice as we mentioned uh yeah I don't
think defending with the king's too
great here because Black's Pawn will
step forward putting more pressure on
the king and if now we block which we
want to do ideally we never want to
touch that black H button then suddenly
um whoops some nasty checks and black
takes control so Simon you think this
one I agree that looks most natural
and you come
I mean I'd love yeah and if you want to
be really funky you throw the Black
Knight in but you also might just look
like a complete idiot you guys try and
lose that and lose that night but it
does force maybe the white king to go go
into the center I mean uh because if the
white thing goes towards the night the
Knight can capture report safely so yeah
we have to go towards the center
and that's quite a weird I mean that's a
very risky way to play really concrete
idea you know because then he's done it
it's done it wow wow okay so well who's
gonna be forced to put her King on that
very odd Square another question is
can we just Checkmate yeah can we just
go for this Pawn but uh I guess this is
just offended by White's Queen perhaps
and is the knight ever gonna get out of
that strange Square because now now the
Black Knight doesn't have anywhere it
can move to so you you could just end up
losing the night so it's a very risky
way for a niche to play uh it seems and
he probably didn't need to do this well
he's gone for an attacking move he's
developed the light Square bishop and
that attacks the the pawn on C4
and again
there's some certain issues how are you
going to defend that I mean are you
going to step forward with the queen are
you just going to
yeah
you could step forward with the queen
defending I use this guy
um
struggling for other ideas here to be
honest pushing this Pawn forward it's
attacked doesn't feel right just because
it feels like we're opening up the
position when White's King is actually
the more vulnerable of the two all that
black needs to do is somehow get a
bishop for example onto this diagonal
and the white king is very awkwardly
placed now almost trapped white has to
throw something in the way to block now
and that would end quite badly so
yeah I mean bad King versus bad Knight
which one is
uh going to decide this game
so if you defend the pawn David is there
any
yeah so I didn't see any follow-up again
nothing concrete as yet
so I just have all I just have a sneaky
feeling he intends to push and kind of
break his Knights uh out to Freedom
forcefully I love seeing a niche play
like this because we're so used to a
niche well not playing the kings in
defense I can't remember ever playing
this opening which is a really exciting
open in the play I I recommend it I
remember talking about Bobby Fisher it
was Bobby Bobby Fisher was really the
player who made this opening from the
black perspective popular
um yeah I mean he Bobby liked playing
for a win as we heard Magnus say and he
he started playing the kings in defense
won loads of great games then Gary
Kasparov played the kings in defense and
David had the the honor of playing in
some of those games and uh but a niche
never plays like this really so it's
great to see him go for the attack and
playing this aggressive way so maybe
it's just that freedom of playing
someone he thinks oh he's a favorite
against someone slightly lower rated
but uh yeah when a niche attacks I've
seen him play fantastically well uh
sometimes it's just maybe fighting
against his instincts sometimes but it
also gives him some Freedom so yeah I
would love to see a move like this one
pushing the pawn to G5 and the whole
idea would be to get the black queen
into the attack uh maybe start opening
up some more lines against the white
king
and uh the night we mentioned looks bad
or black but it is very safely defended
by the bishop for now
uh White's a bit tied up White's night
White's Queen they're tied down to
defending this Pawn on C4 Square
see David when you're attack you're a
natural G5 is a great move I mean like I
know you prefer your grinding nowadays
but I want to see you play would you
play the Kings in defense for me
yeah Olympiad don't give your prep away
yeah
if you please please play G5 now Anish
oh come on Queen has defended this Pawn
okay process of elimination what else
the black Rook looks nice but it has no
entry squares in White's half of the
board you don't really want to ever
touch this bishop it's your best piece
this Knight's doing a good job attacking
this uh C4 Pawn Bishop's doing a good
job
the only pieces you can really improve
for black are these two but blackstruck
is great we want to improve the queen
therefore open up a square for her that
would be my thinking at least
and whites I mean the clear Target in
White's Camp is the king so we need to
get towards it you could also make an
argument for this move uh trying to
threaten some checkmates try to take
this Pawn actually the white king would
be trapped there
this would be on the radar too but I
love your G5 yeah I think it's C5 move
is the winner probably because it's
something else everything else just uh
feels a little bit slow here you know
you've accelerated the play and the
pressure is on due you know to come up
with a good defensive move I mean
White's pieces is on a real tangle
um it's very difficult to even suggest
single piece to improve themselves I
mean we talked about blacks pieces white
tonight stuck defending the spawn
White's Queen defending this Pawn
White's Knight if it ever moves then it
would allow maybe the black Rook to come
into the position uh White's Rook start
defending this bishop this bishop stuck
defending its Knight
King unable to move on the board and
then she's attacking yes
we love it we love Anish attacking this
is just great stuff and David you saw
this idea straight away as well so I
mean I'm just trying to channel my inner
Gary Kasparov what would he do he would
throw all the pieces towards the white
kid and I can ask you about that because
obviously this this game's really
heating up and it seems like Niche is
going for this final Onslaught but
playing Kasparov in some Blitz Games and
some rapid games you know he he's
considered to be the one of the best
players if not the best player of all
time and uh you you're over at his house
and that must how what was that like it
was scary I mean I'm always scared when
I play these top guys just because
they're so good but he has this Aura
around him he's especially strong he was
world champion for what was it 15 years
and number one for longer so
it was intimidating we ended up playing
on a balcony in Croatia by the beach and
he was just in shorts so I was like wait
have I been tricked into some uh some
holiday but
um but yeah once the game started he was
really intense and I remember so we
played nine rapid Games first and then
18 Blitz Games but the rapid games we
kind of discussed what openings I would
try and test him in what openings I
would play because he was about to make
a comeback and play another tournament
in St Louis
and he said okay test me in some Kings
Indians play some Kings Indians and I
was like no but that's your strong point
and that's my weekend but I ended up
playing similar openings to uh to this
one to Zhu and June and what she's doing
right now and I think I just got
checkmated three times in the first my
first three white games and I just
thought you know I didn't even make any
blunders I was just getting checkmated
he would just build up all his pieces
and then break through and I just
thought I mean this guy he's just
not I mean he's Unstoppable it's just
the energy he'd been retired for 12
years at this point uh from classical
Chess at least so I can remember I met
him once and the thing you say about his
Aura his energy is totally true I mean a
friend of mine won the under 18 World
Championships and they had something
that houses a parliament and he was
supposed to invite his brother-in-law I
had to pretend to be his brother to get
in Houses of Parliament a little bit
strange but Gary Kasparov was there and
uh you know and it was free champagne as
well so I I went out to get Gary
Kasparov with my rosy cheeks at the time
and it you could just feel There's
Something About Him special it's like
some magic he just had this energy which
some people do just like something some
Aura of like I'm a powerful person about
him and he was it was quite intimidating
I have to say because he just there's
some magic around him really so yeah but
um yeah I mean a brilliant player and
one of the best players ever in the
king's Indian defense if not the best
player the best player probably of all
time so yeah I have to say my
experiences of all the world champions
that I've met they have a very similar
Aura you know you you kind of feel that
they are Killers you know they have this
ruthlessness to them but what comes
first that's aura or the world
championship title does it come with the
title or is it certain players I just I
just feel that they they get this they
have this Aura I mean they have that
dedication of ruthlessness that they
really you know when you're sat there
facing them over the board they want to
rip you apart you know and and with most
other Grandmasters I would say you don't
get that feeling you kind of get the
feeling kids chest is chess you know
it's an enjoyment it's a blood spot blah
blah blah but you know it's but with
them even in day I mean I remember
bumping into karpov and the lift and
maybe it was just me but you know I felt
that he had very very icy eyes and he's
very piercing and he just looked at me
and I could feel like he was assessing
my whole character my whole being like a
[ __ ] yeah like like if no he was not a
fish I remember I remember
famously said his name means
everything like him is a fish he's a
fish
a piece of fish slimy fish yeah but I
can tell you he was no fish and it
didn't really help Mata that I actually
you know I needed to go to the ground
floor and I got off in the mezzanine and
I flounced off and I was like oh my
goodness me I'm gonna have to walk back
into the lift and he's gonna know that
I've met Elementary mistake of getting
off the wrong floor and I was like no I
can't put her faces I'm gonna have to
just live by my mistake and walk down
those stairs
so uh yeah oh well the world champions
We do have a world champion in this game
Jew engine women's world champion and a
bunch of moves the bar going up for a
niche now yeah a bunch of moves and
actually the Queens have come off the
board so no big attack this game is not
going to end in uh Checkmate in the next
couple of moves but
actually I just it just feels like
White's position is collapsing feels
like it's all falling apart
oh I was gonna say no checkmates but
that one is brutal I was expecting back
tonight to jump in but instead The Rook
dives into the position what a beautiful
move David wonderful move
um we should just backtrack a couple of
moves we saw this uh incredible
attacking idea from uh Anish giri white
did not want to have seed that black
queen jump into the action so instead
Jew and June Force the Queen's off which
is understandable but uh it's come at
the price of opening up pods for the
black Rooks and look at these two black
Rooks this line this line they're both
going to come in at some point and after
Pawn takes Pawn not reacting to the
attack on his Knight and he should
instead jumped in and threatened
Checkmate Rook takes Pawn would happen
for example Paul takes Knight and uh
this would end in Checkmate so this is a
mating net the white king sits in
thinks the only way to save herself is
to retreat this Knight but it's hanging
by a thread No Escape squares for the
king now
what is the killer blow um that black
knight jumping in is very tempting isn't
it at some point jumping maybe and it's
funny that one of the killer pieces is
that weird Black Knight on the edge of
the board as well creating those
Checkmate fronts and and you know
pinning the king the white king dad to
where it is at the moment but this is uh
looks very scary for white White's
Pieces Just huddling there on the back
rank I'm looking at lines like this one
so the Black Knight jumping in if white
plays Bishop takes Bishop can we just
ignore it and jump in with the other
Rook to threaten a nasty Checkmate again
I mean this looks so scary for uh for
white maybe white can survive here by
eliminating we've been talking about it
a long time eliminating that night on
the edge of the board but I mean it's
super scary for for Zhu and June right
now this night move is the obvious one
maybe there are others uh maybe The Rook
can jump in immediately to the second
rank
ing that one as well but I hadn't worked
out the details
but uh goodness me this position is
scary I mean just looking at the bar the
bar's like it's completely lost for
whites and uh definitely party time for
Anish yeah he's got eight and a half
minutes against two and a half as well
so huge advantage on the clock it
definitely feels like he's more familiar
with the plans the ideas in this type of
position and now it's just about the
details working out what to play first I
mean bringing the knight in looks so
natural can't be a mistake if the Knight
is ever captured this is just going to
end in disaster for the white king
um so this would be maybe the safe
alternative
um yeah I mean bring the Rook forward as
well just looks too tempting
just with the idea that if the white
Bishop moves then you can actually
sacrifice your Rook with a checkmate
all the checkmates will just show them
as they come on the board but also the
idea is if the Black Knight is captured
the black Bishop can just jump in and
still some pressure along the second
rank once the black Bishop Retreats on
the next turn
the two black Rooks are going to be the
dominant pieces just look how active
they are compared to White pieces right
now all of White's pieces kind of
huddled together and it does play this
yeah it is uh well the black pieces are
just having fun fun fun here and there's
nothing to do I can't see a single
defensive move I mean you might just
have to at some point just trade off
this really strong black knight and just
to get your king briefing again but two
Bishops against two knights now let's
clear the Bishops are better I mean the
bishop will just Retreat and the
domination this reminds me of a carpool
Kasparov game actually from the World
Champ chips uh one of the most famous
ones with Casper one with the black
pieces where car post piece were just in
the middle on the back rank huddling
around
um uh there was some great great fights
in in their encounters like this yeah
just kind of barely Clinging On yeah
they're hanging by the thread sort of
Discord you know all defending all
passive and Casper I mean Casper was
brilliant with the energy he gave us
pieces he just somehow you know they
they jumped into life uh like no one
else's pieces yeah looking very very
good for Anish Gary in the current
position computer maybe thinks that some
small transfer shoe engine but uh in
Practical terms it's all gone against
her she's down to one minute and these
two Rooks are gonna do significant
damage in the near future
we do see a result Arjun nargaisi has
won his game against Jeffrey Sean and
that means that the youngest player in
the tournament is currently in the lead
if Samuel Savion loses two young crest
of Duda in this round then ergasi will
have the the sole lead heading into the
final round and the preliminaries he's
playing a fantastic tournament and he
has won one two three four of the five
last games Arjun in a great shape
yeah I mean he's been the man of the
year for me the last 12 months really I
should never go see 20 21 2022
I mean the improvements I mean he's
gained a couple of hundred points since
the pandemic started but not just that
he's knocking on the door of 2700 he
he's won so many events
and it looks like he's still got so much
room to improve yeah um I've talked
about him with some of the top players
in the world and they think he's going
to make that next step up already so I
mean the likes of him and Prague might
be the two
um to join the world's Elite and
he's beating everyone at the moment in
this tournament Arjun fantastic we can
take a look at the current standings
actually it's very interesting to follow
only eight players will qualify for The
Knockout stage and uh Muhammad yarov on
18 points same as Anish giri and Levon
aronian heading into this round and
Lavon bar is roughly to the middle in
his game against Linea Dominguez mama
diarov could he be about to lose against
Aryan tari and that's going to be
dramatic for chakra if levonne is able
and the niche is able to get points in
this round it's going to be uh outside
top eight if he loses this game
wow
yeah some really wild positions
especially in the manager of games so
wow yeah nobody's safe yet
just those top guys I guess the
youngsters they can relax a bit yeah
that's uh the more experienced players
all to play for and meanwhile that
variation we actually showed a few
moments ago has happened on the board we
did see a couple of exchanges so it's
two Bishops against two knights right
now
and does Anish Gary have the time to
just save one of his Bishops and we just
I would Retreat the dark Squad Bishop
somewhere I'm not sure where but yeah I
agree I mean
maybe maybe you don't have to worry
about your Pawn you can just put it in
the middle and you can move your king up
two Bishops are very strong but uh at
least White's not losing immediately
that's that's about the only thing I can
say about you know good about White's
position because it was looking like
there could be a Checkmate a couple of
moves ago yeah we haven't seen Jew enter
in smart for a while that says the door
though what about White's position
unfortunately
I just feel that the black Rooks they're
so strong on the second row I mean I
think that those two Rooks combined just
going to be a killer Duo
I think White's position is just gonna
crack
yep it's just about making it crack
vanish Gary finding the way to crack the
white position
she's covered everything
so uh she might need to take the time
out he does treat his Bishop to a great
Square I think the problem here is that
white doesn't really have any moves
right I mean if you let's just say you
move your king forwards again this the
strategy is trying to find the best move
for your opponent not looking at your
own moves but looking at your opponent's
moves it's a great strategy to improve
um because if you find that your
opponent doesn't have any moves or the
moves are going to make their position
worse it's actually best to wait and
there's a phrase you wait until they
basically implode you don't have to
force the issue and I don't know maybe
white has some ways to improve but I
can't see many good moves so I don't see
it at all I mean this Knight is stuck
otherwise the bishop will break through
in this diagonal
um this Knight is stuck uh sorry this
one is stuck defending this Pawn okay he
has actually played this move that you
mentioned there Simon just going towards
this Pawn now as black
um yeah so these two knights are stuck
just trying to hold everything together
if these nights are stuck it means this
Rook cannot break out either
um I mean this Rook is stuck defending
this Pawn
these pawns just immobilized if you push
any of them forward they'll just drop
totally and uh black has a past Pawn as
well I mean it's not it's not that far
Advanced but it could be yeah later it
has a clear run through and um I mean
maybe the only piece that can move
safely right now is the king but uh if
the king moves forward yes you kick the
bishop but the bishop can just Retreat
somewhere and the King actually finds
itself on a really uncomfortable uh file
rank anyway
so
it's like zigsbank really you just have
to go back and sit and wait she doesn't
have too much time on the clock and she
made that move with eight seconds to
Spur okay King moves Bishop is going to
retreat yeah just I think this is the
safest Square okay he goes back I was
gonna suggest this one as well but I was
reluctant to even dream of allowing an
exchange
a Trader one set of pieces due engine
has less than five seconds on the clock
and she makes a trade and again is
forced to defend Pawns passively
yeah but now she's still in Zoo look at
the White Knight look at the white Rooks
they're all stuck defending nice stable
yeah the same I got it we've got it on
the board of the daytime yeah it is on
the board and uh the king is marching up
the pawn the sea porn is also going to
start marching forward yeah you can push
that black seaport now the black king
can just munch on a pawn
there we go
I wouldn't even touch that Black Sea
Pawn right now I would just use the
black king just to go and take
everything
that's because you want to get to move a
hundred
you'd probably triangulate a couple of
times on the way you know
have you ever have you had that urge to
like move your king to every Square on
the board before you make progress oh no
don't say you have in bullet chests I've
done that a few times I had a 305 move
bullet game once 305. I had two queens
trapping my opponent's king and then I
just went to every Square on the board
then I pushed the pawn then every Square
on the board
and then I stalemated him on me
how could you make 305 moves in a bullet
game in one minute yeah so 60 seconds
you made 305 moves yeah that's my record
at least that's how many moves okay let
me I can work this out 1600 it might
take me a while the pressure in the
meantime a win for young Crystal dude
against Samuel Savion the first loss for
young Samuel in the tournament you're
still safe to qualify but this means the
youngest player in the tournament Arjun
there guys he is in top off the table
wow impressive stuff
it's like five six moves a second yeah
I'm sorry I just went yeah that's that's
pretty impressive yeah wow with the
mouse it's possible the pre-moves over
the Border would be a bit trickier but
uh yeah we should say Duda first of all
great result for him he must be closing
in on Magnus now but uh Sam's heavy on
first defeat of the tournament yeah how
will he bounce back
that's a big question now going forward
and also uh the problem for these
youngsters they're playing fantastic
Chester on top of the table but the
problem is these Top Guns the the
favorites before the tournament they're
doing like so and so so they're going to
face these players and The Knockout
stage versus a whole different story
correct so right now wouldn't it be
origin against the niche perhaps yeah
you dominate you think oh my reward will
be an easier powering Knockouts and then
you play
life isn't a fact yeah it's brutal the
only
um the only tournament Arjun played last
season was the gold money Asian rap but
he did make it to the court finals to
Faith levonne right yes could you have
it so like you've got eight people who
qualify the top four pick who they play
just have it like a little bit drama
because it's like why are you picking me
you know it's like you know so the
person who comes top can pick his
opponent yeah pick her opponent I think
that'd be quite it'd be quite
controversial because it's like you know
you could really hone in on people it's
like oh come on but it'll be quite
interesting yeah and it's kind of the
opposite from when you have uh pickings
in gym class for example you want to be
the one picked first yeah here it's kind
of yeah I don't know and we have a
result uh Juan Jun has lost to Anish
Gary three points for a niche three very
important points for a niche but now
it's looking very good